welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther wakanda forever
pulled off the near impossible task of a
successful follow-up to the 2018 black
panther film and thrilling MCU
installment despite tragically losing
Chadwick Boseman right before production
of the sequel was set to begin after a
draft of a previous version of black
panther 2 was written in 2020 and as
someone who's written a few screenplays
myself and read hundreds more I am
copyrighter Joe Robert Cole Weber to
accomplish and the way they were able to
relatively quickly reconceive this
narrative as one focused instead on
shuri evolving the character into an
instrument of grief that taught
audiences both out of mourn Chadwick
Boseman and t'challa and how to process
the death of any loved one in our lives
this is especially impressive now that
these creatives are opening up about
what that original 2020 script draft
looked like this week an in-depth
interview with the co-writer Joe Robert
Cole and cryptic mentions that you might
have missed in other articles upon this
movie's release about other characters
who originally gonna be killed off
instead of Ramona and when exactly
elements like namora talukan and even
t'challa's son to Saint came into the
story so for the sake of celebrating the
challenges and triumphs of the
filmmaking and screenwriting processes
let's break down everything we know
about this original script of black
panther 2 what would what kind of
forever app looks like with t'challa in
it well according to director Ryan
coogler this second black panther film
was always going to be one about
wakanda's relationship with namora's
rival Kingdom in a podcast interview
that Ryan cooglers did with tanahasi
coats kukler said that as early as late
2018 months after the first black
panther was released and the movie was
starting to get Oscar buzz boogler began
to have meetings with Marvel Studios
about what the sequel was going to be I
know I wanted to make another one you
know when I was doing my deep dive you
know all of his stories there were like
a few characters that he would interact
with I thought man this is just like
this this would be awesome and I'm new
that like it would be calling killmonger
for the first one but Neymar was like
all over these books and it was always
really interesting if we ran it back it
would be about him and name one and we
would introduced Marvel's Atlantis to
the fall the co-writer Joe Robert Cole
confirmed to Rolling Stone that no more
was always going to be the antagonist of
this movie and that they had always
wanted to bring in Marvel's Atlantis
because yeah in the comics t'challa's
biggest rival really is Neymar but since
the DC's Aquaman was going to be coming
out at the end of 2018 they really went
in deeper they changed Atlantis to
talocon basing it all on Mesoamerican
mythology googler also said the movie
was going to explore t'challa more as a
person second script was like a t'challa
vehicle it was like okay we set the
world up now we're gonna like do it the
deepest dive into this guy that you
could imagine and that was what excited
me even more because I knew Chad better
as a performer and as I knew him better
as a guy yeah notice how googler said
that there were certain biographical
elements about Chadwick Boseman as a
human being that he wanted to bring in
to inspire the character of t'challa and
specifically at this period the
relationship between the two men
Chadwick Bozeman was tragically planning
a wedding with his partner Simone Hubler
also confirmed in this podcast that he
finished his draft in August 2020 and
brought it to Chadwick Boseman to read
my last conversation with him was
calling him asking him if he wanted to
read it before I got lost from the
studio that was the last time we spoke
you know he passed maybe a couple weeks
after I finished and then he was like
yeah he didn't want her he said he
didn't want to read it because uh he
didn't want to get in the way whatever
notion Studio might have or what have
you so he was like it's better for him
to read it later I thought letter that
he was he was too tired to read anything
yes this is a very heavy but meaningful
podcast with some really deep moments of
Ryan coogler I highly recommend you
listen to it but from this we know that
coogler's 2020 draft was a rivalry
between t'challa and Neymar two kingdoms
exploring t'challa as a family man and a
political leader debating whether to
join forces with Neymar in the war
against the surface World essentially
the conflict that shurin ramonda faced
as rulers and representatives of the
kingdom of wakanda interesting to also
know that Google are always intended on
calling back killmonger from the
ancestral plane Cole also confirmed that
in the Rolling Stone interview that
killmonger's ancestral plane return was
always going to be in the works the
difference was that in the 2020 draft
this return was going to be a rematch
with t'challa perhaps not a physical
rematch but a war of words similar to
powerful speech that killmonger gives
shuri but upon wakanda forever's release
there was another in-depth article from
variety that kind of got buried by the
opening weekend headlines but in that
article there was one mysterious
paragraph that reveals quite a bit it
reads as is often the case with Marvel
Studios Productions the screenplay was a
largely fluid document from
pre-production all the way through the
Final Cut of the film an early subplot
for the United States featured more
prominently in the confrontation between
wakanda and telecon was dialed down
while the incident that launches the
third act shifted Focus to different
characters So reading between those
lines two things there essentially a U.S
invasion of wakanda and then a different
incident that launches the third act
focusing on different characters now of
course the US invasion of wakanda is
hinted at in the scene with Val in the
Secretary of State but we never actually
see it they don't get there yet maybe
Marvel Studios to save that for a future
title like Thunderbolts now black
panther what kind of forever offers an
optimistic view of the future wakanda
will last forever but sometimes the
pressure of Four River can be
overwhelming and it's helpful to just
say what's going on right now well inbox
tattoos can help with that ink box
tattoos last one to two weeks so you can
express yourself with a tattoo for the
mood you were in right now without
worrying about whether or not you'll
want it well forever there are over 10
000 tattoo designs to choose from you
can even create your own totally unique
tattoo easily using inkbox's custom
platform and if you're a pro artist or
an avid doodler you can draw your own
tattoo with one of inkbox's freehand
tattoo markers now I chose the uh Booboo
ghost tattoo I really like ghosts I like
this design I'm gonna put it right here
on my wrist now applying the tattoos
really easy you just take this primer
wipe you rub the area to clean it right
nice and Prime feel it you place it and
you stick it
all right it's stuck this tattoo is
going to develop over the next 24 hours
to a dark blue or a black color
depending on your skin let's give it a
day and see what happens
and check it out it's already starting
to come in see unlike other temporary
tattoos ink boxes ink sinks into the top
layer of your skin and after a week or
two it fades as your skin naturally
regenerates the ink is plant-based
cruelty free and water resistant and
here we are I'm ghosted in the good kind
of ghost dude ink box tattoos are
perfect for switching up your style
testing out your next tattoo idea and
make for Unique gifts for the upcoming
holiday so right now you can use code
new rock stars to get 25 off your entire
ink box order there's no minimum order
requirement but you can only use it once
so stock up the code will only be good
until the end of 2022 to get started
with inkbox just click the link in the
description and start browsing but that
act 3 incident structurally refers to
the death of Queen ramonda and Cheri
scene killmonger in The ancestral plane
the final version of the movie that is
the sequence that ends the second act
when shuri reaches her lowest point the
sequence that ends with shuri powering
up is a new Black Panther and
confronting Neymar in the teleconneal in
the final battle the third act so this
variety quote is glossing over the fact
that in a previous draft either a
different character was going to be
killed off instead of Ramona and or
shuri was going to see a different
character in The ancestral plane than
killmonger now to be clear coal
confirmed that it was never considered
to use CGI to recreate the likeness of
Chadwick Boseman but it is possible that
a past version of wakanda forever
featured instead of Ramona dying the
death of a character like bukoye or
umbaku if you think about it in a
version of this movie where t'challa was
the hero embaku's death would have been
made gritty devastating loss Neymar
would have killed t'challa's strongest
Ally t'challa's Mercutio something that
feels like it could have still survived
to the later version of this movie
considering baku's brotherly status to
shuri and how relatively little he now
has to do in the final battles movie
like they kind of had to come up with
stuff for him to do in the final fight
now yes they did bring back in Baka to
Warrior Falls to claim the throne but
when it comes to the final battle as fun
as it is to watch him fight he can't
really say he's much of a game changer
in the title of that war now Cole does
admit that they definitely played around
with the idea of making Baku the Black
Panther of this movie altogether but
pretty early on they settled on shuri
being the most impactful vocal character
of this kind of story and then after
they made that decision they shifted to
all other characters into shuri's orbit
really the most surprising thing to
learn about the original 2020 script
draft was according to Nicole t'challa
having a son was always going to be part
of this movie he said that t'challa had
a child in this script prior to Chad's
passing and was always in the DNA of
what they wanted to do Cole even said
that this 2020 draft was more quote
child focused and then that element was
more reduced after Bozeman's death Cole
said they went back and forth on when to
introduce Toussaint originally playing
to straight up named the kid the first
time we see him with her motive visits
Haiti but later they decided to just
show the kid in that scene and then
introduce him by his name in the final
scene so what does more child focus mean
well Ryan coogler might have given us
the answer in another interview he did
with inverse in early November where he
revealed about the earlier draft quote
the tone was going to be similar the
character was going to be grieving the
loss of time you know coming back after
being gone for five years as a man with
so much responsibility to so many coming
back after a forced five years absence
that's what the film was tackling he was
grieving time he couldn't get back Reed
was a big part of it the loss of time a
forced five-year absence that really
does sound like this was going to be
about t'challa having missed out on the
early years of his son's life he was
obviously pregnant with t'challa Junior
before the snap and gave birth to him
shortly after t'challa having been
dusted for that time meant that he was
gone for like the first five years of
his son's life and coogler wanted to
explore the theme of fathers being taken
away from their sons and then suddenly
coming back in those kids lives and
struggling to be respected paternal
figures if you look back at Ryan
coogler's work this is a very important
theme to him as a filmmaker and by the
way Marvel Studios did totally repackage
this relationship with Scott Lang and
Cassie Ling and Ant-Man the WASP
onomania Wisconsin last five years so
Cassie being the one valuable piece of
Leverage that Kang uses to incentive by
Scott into helping him but one could
only imagine the deeper layers of impact
that would have been had we seen it with
t'challa and his son so here's a quick
summary of what the original black
panther 2 2020 script draft most likely
was one t'challa returns from the blip
and deals with having been an absent
father to his son to the United States
actually invades wakanda Bree Namor
confronts t'challa and challenges him
into joining the fight against the other
nations of Earth leading to a fight
between the two kingdoms wakanda versus
tawacan for killmonger returns to the
ancestral plain but tests t'challa maybe
even tries to convert to chala's son to
his ideology and five a different
character dies in raimonda maybe umbaku
now again the point of all this
sleuthing isn't to say the previous
version would have been better but
really do appreciate how story elements
shift involve over time and to respect
the creative team for finding a new way
into the story while redeploying these
elements in service of a more impactful
theme about loss you can follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you